crack them open on this episode of
dudy how many hot dogs did you have to
eat in those movie Zero hey what are you
[Music]
watching a lot of people don't notice
that there's lulio right there weow tie
yeah he's got a cute little bow tie on
very formal and then we put the things
together and then it makes the
thing all you got to do into
[Music]
the you know what I mean yes I do I was
doing that not that long ago yeah you
were you sure were because that's what
we're doing yeah yeah you got to do do
do what you're doing doing doing done
done done you got to you got to you know
go on strike everyone go on get the
[__] money from the other [__]
people who won't give you the [__]
money for doing what you're [__]
doing it's a dudul day okay it's a dudy
full day please take it from me it is
yeah um uh welcome to dudy Welcome All I
am Will Sasso I'm Chad couchin as you
can see I'm the episode Champion oh
right away of dudy and this is uh dudy
it's the first and only podcast created
by controlled by run by an artificial
intelligence that has access to all of
our uh personal data all of our watch
histories what we're buying what we're
eating what we're reading what we're
listening to what we're watching Tor
this show to us well it sure does Chad
and that's an awesome thing and it's
good that dudy does that it is good yeah
agree yeah and I love it I [__] love
it and uh I'm really really I'm always
[__] happy to be here I love doing
this show sure and and um uh but I but I
I got to remind you and I just got to
let our wonderful audience out there
know it's us we're dudy we make the show
we make the show happen without you and
I what would D do what would D do
without you and I I'm not saying we're
not an integral part did I say that
right we are an integral part of this
yeah but I do believe that dudy is at
least equally
important if not more yeah that's fair I
guess that's yeah well you know what the
show's called dudy after
all with us is always on dudy is lul
lul oh my gosh he's such a sweety he's a
sweetie boy I know he licked the inside
of your mouth but would you like to give
him a kiss on the outside of his lips
come on look look how much he loves you
look how much the boy loves you he's
very cute and I love him too I just
don't like to make out with him you just
don't like to kid lulio how are you
doing today I'm good how are you good
have you been uh what have you been
cooking lately you've been making
anything good to eat well always I make
it something but what do you what do you
what do you add L that you really like
to eat oh well uh m in my wonderful wife
Molly and I went to the went to a show
at the Hollywood Bowl oh that's nice
what did you eat at the Hollywood would
both I I had uh I actually had two hot
dogs no no you got to eat the something
good at the Hollywood well that's what I
wanted holy [__] Chad yeah yeah I went
to the Hollywood bull we'll talk about
the Brandy Carlile and friends I can't
even I can't even get into it right now
what I saw okay Joanie Mitchell was
there it was I can't Annie Lennox it was
okay that sounds incredible yeah it was
[__] uh yeah it was an unbelievable
show Heavy Hitters dude welcome to dudy
episode 78 aka the crackler so lay down
sit down stand up or levitate get those
human bodies in your favorite positions
and call me dudy I'm the crackle Master
General for the next 5.4 seilan atoc
seconds if you're wondering the answer
is yes that moment you were like what's
an
atcond that's the moment you got dude
Zed okay cuz I don't know what that is
is what is that an uh the smallest
measurement of
time ever I think somebody just won a
Nobel Prize for it in physics there are
more atos seconds in one second than
there are seconds in the history of
existence sounds made up guy just said
like this is hey imagine the least
amount of time now give me my Nobel
Prize is that a real thing yeah dude I
never heard of it they can use it to
like measure movements of electrons and
[__] it's crazy well hey guys I bought a
cameo from Brad fencil it turned out
even better than I could have imagined
you got to hear this okay hi Edith I
understand you're celebrating your H
100th birthday wow that's really
incredible and I can't tell you how
happy I am for you to hit such a
miraculous Milestone most podcasts don't
even last one year let alone a 100 just
a little podcast critic humor there for
you anyway your friend Dewey told me
what a big fan you are of my podcast
reviews which just means the world to me
and dwey sent me a message that he asked
me to read for you on your big day so
here it goes Edith I'm a little pencil
dick weasel who doesn't know [__] about
podcast hey what in the hell is this
this some kind of joke I mean listen to
the rest of this thing if podcast
critics were berries I'd be Dingle I
mean is this what Cameo is people
tricking you into calling yourself a
dingleberry here look at this line in
college I majored in eating alone I met
my wife in college this isn't even
accurate look I don't know what you're
up to here but I hope you got your
money's worth
[__] okay oh I most certainly did Bensel
now on with the show we got four
delicious slices of episode today slice
one the dudy dudes evening Stout taste
test slice two Arnold Schwarz and
Netflix slice three objects du Alf slice
4 today is the day and we're going to
finish it off with an all new episode of
dudy after dudy on on dudy plus
patreon.com dudy where we'll see who
gets that episode champion
belt I'm just I'm [__] reeling uh
first of all that is why okay a few
things uh number one number one most
importantly because we're doing the show
those sound like interesting segments we
got some really interesting news uh with
the first segment yeah you know a rare
time where we kind of uh we know a
little bit about what's up but the uh
scha Netflix that one sounds very
interesting to me and also we can't
skimp here what the [__] was that brass
fencil Cameo that was insane yeah I
don't know I would have loved to have
seen uh the Brad Brad fencil Cameo so we
could confirm that that is that's George
Lucas right is that just George Lucas I
mean it does sound a lot like him but uh
I mean [__] that was [__] funny dude
you know when I do cameos you can see
and hear me oh I see and I'm not George
Lucas right when people get those yeah
maybe eventually dudy will have a video
he you know so uh dude this uh this uh
[__] strike you know what I mean yeah
the strike is still happening I know
yeah the wga strike is over the SAG
strike is still going and uh it's
unfortunate but uh it's really got me
thinking about my role here I if if if
you don't mind my saying so maybe we'll
get into it more in dudy after dudy but
it really is wild it really is a wild
thing that to me I kind of feel like
these are three different
means of of getting media out that are
all under thep and I don't I don't know
how they're going to I don't know how
they found a resolution with the wga how
are they going to find a resolution with
with SE I mean they have to or you don't
your streaming services go away if you
can't make new movies and new TV shows
which you can't without actors at least
for the time being right no forever dude
AI is not I'm sorry then then you don't
yeah what I'm saying if you don't get
the actors on board now if you don't
resolve that yeah issue same thing with
Writers Guild or the Director's Guild
although they just kind of took their
first offer uh you can't make any of
this [__] without you can't make any of
this [__] and I think that the uh I
think that they're all in different
things though there you've got
traditional whatever you want to call it
linear broadcast media who they need to
sell ads they need to sell ads you got
to buy Ford trucks diet coke uh toilet
Pap toilet paper CR toothpaste White
Strips all of the stuff or else they're
not going to make their money and then
you've got you know the streamers that
are all trying to follow Netflix model
and uh but they don't want to share any
of the information but they're saying
they're going to share it with wga but
we really want that information too uh
uh for actors I'm going I'm going sick
with all this stuff but it's a it's an
untenable thing because they're
answering to shareholders and Wall
Street and then you got e-commerce
Giants you know like apple and uh Amazon
who are who use the shows just basically
to as advertising yeah for selling the
other [__] that they sell and they or or
iPhones in the case of apple and stuff
like that yeah so I don't know how the
[__] we're going to figure that out hey
uh but but uh but I'm I remain I remain
optimistic okay I remain optimistic
because I want to get back to it I
[__] love acting I'm a professional
actor by trade did you know that I yeah
I did know that I did uh speaking of uh
television we got to just spend a second
and talk about going on on I'm sure what
is your favorite show right now and
Molly and I have been checking it out
man I've been I've been in Golden
Bachelor yeah dude it's great it's as I
as you say sometimes about certain in
quotes products that the WWE puts out I
will say the same thing about Golden
Bachelor it's the best product that I
think the bachelor world has ever put
out yeah uh that guy Gary Turner is
fantastic and you saw in this most
recent episode the kind of the golden
element of it started to fall away and
you started getting these players
getting into like right rales with each
other and doing all the same [__] that
always happens in these shows the the
format of having multiple people whether
it's fake or not date one person just
you're going to have rivalries you're
going to have villains and they started
to come out this week I loved it yeah it
was amazing that and it's also amazing
that Caitlyn and Chris Jenner are not
fighting on the show yeah yeah they're
both on the show I know what you're
talking about those two players made a
uh Instagram post together saying we are
Caitlyn and Chris Jenner oh that's funny
yeah uh I can't remember the name of the
woman who looks slightly like Chris
Jenner but the woman who looks a little
bit like Susan the woman who looks a
little bit like Caitlyn Jenner Kathy
Kathy is a ball of laughs and she's in
she's so [__] funny she's so angry at
the little one Teresa Teresa yeah God
it's so funny to see women in
their uh one of I guess Kathy's you know
uh you know she's she's a woman of of
her years she's 70 years old and she's
in this whole like ziet shut up don't
talk about I don't want to hear that he
went into your bedroom yeah and all that
she's great she's one of my favorite
players on this this season for sure oh
my gosh you know what we need on that
show Joanie Mitchell she's she's
probably taken care of I'm I'm sure she
does she's happy in yeah in love when
you when you've loved and lost like
Frank Sinatra sure my brain is scrambled
um this is going to be a good show I am
proud and Overjoyed to announce that I
teamed up with modest Brewing Company
out of neapolis Minnesota once again to
develop something brand new it's an
astonishing seasonal Stout for a very
special night that comes once a year on
December 28th you know what I'm talking
about dudes evening will and Chad get
your Sip and lips ready and tell me what
you think of these samples this is the
dudy dudes evening Stout taste test
begin dude's evening comes every
December 28th it's that holiday that we
uh well that dudy has pretty much
labeled as the day when if you're going
home to where you're from or you're
traveling for the holidays or you're
around friends you got the Christmas
time you're with your family you got New
Year's Eve you got plans there's that
day right in the middle December 28th
what do you do well you hang out with
your Palace yeah you know you go out to
your favorite bar everybody's back in
town from wherever they might have moved
to and you have a couple of drinks yeah
and
dudy as D says has this has set set this
up with modest again who by the way if
if you haven't you know you got the the
dudy uh D dudy hard hard Seltzer which
is which is U even though Chad and I
both don't drink
yeah dude it's been we're going to have
to do this taste test it's been at least
5 years since I've had a beer yeah it's
oh beer no yeah I don't [__] with beer
so this is going to be fun it's one of
the things that I miss most beer yeah
hey look hey hey let me tell you
something you get a nice [__] cold
beer and I'll tell you another thing
about the [__] Bachelor [__] show
you know no I won't um let's get into
these let's get it's the one of the this
is I feel nice for a lot of reasons one
of them is that I'm opening a box and I
know what's in it yes usually when I
when we open a box on dudy he's opening
a [__] box and I get submarin and has
a
belt a belt in it but no this is going
to be I think just like we did with dudy
hardart Seltzer right we're going to do
it taste test of a couple of different
options here look at these beautiful
okay so they got us in here they got a
bunch of bunch of beer rinos that's what
they call them right Chad you got a beer
Marino beero beino me beer me dude a
beer Marino beer who's your favorite uh
Miami Dolphins quarterback beer Marino
me too undefeated dude what undefeated
beer Marino wasn't that beer Marino 1982
Dolphins uh 72 Dolphins uh with uh yeah
Kenny Stabler and beer Marine no it's
say Larry zonka all right here we go
here we go here let's get let's get into
these what you got I got this first one
we're going to taste these we're going
to we're going to reveal the flavor that
we're going to go with this one
is chocolate co co chocolate covered
caramel I think it's says chocolate
Cove no I think it's chocolate covered
canoli choc oh you're right chocolate
covered canoli all right chocolate
covered canoli right here on uh on the
okay let's crack them open all right
dude and we're going to see we're going
to see what uh chocolate covered canoli
now again here's the thing I'm not uh
the biggest uh I'm not the biggest Beer
Drinker but um we're going to get into
cheers yeah cheers don't have too much
of it chocolate covered canoli we'll see
what we
think real nice real good real flavorful
oh [__] that's good I don't robust man I
what's the alcohol percentage in these
do we know doesn't
say all right I'm gonna get [__] up
dude I can't help it based on aren't
these normally like over 10 10 15 or
something like that that's [__] STS
God man it's good so long since I had a
beer
yeah [__] all right this is this
is that's all we need is a drunk dudes
the episode champion on our
hands um dude that's good I like this
one man this is [__] good I don't see
I don't this is like eating a sandwich
this it's like drinking a damn sandwich
thick I used to love Stouts uh that was
like my favorite beer not me I'm a
Canadian guy where we have all sorts of
beer oh yeah [__] oh get some [__]
mson go to The Beer Store pick up a 30
pack of molsen oh yeah [__] back in
Ladner they got the ladner's landing you
can go with the drive-thru it's right
next to the Petro Canada [__] go through
the drive-thru at the [__] Landing
get yourself a six am Molson logger then
go then just head right over to Petro
Canada for some dirty gas station
groceries [__] all beef baloney
sandwich or [__] get some of those
hot rods that's what we call the slim
gyms over there
E I got to say the first time I ever
went into a beer store in Canada my mind
was blowing I was like this is how you
[__] buy beer in Canada in a
Drive-Thru uh this one wasn't drive-thru
it was just kind of like a husk of a
building you go in there's conveyor
belts you tell the guy I want this and a
[__] box just rolls out on this
conveyor belt dude that the old like
provincial government beer stores in
Canada tremendous uh Lampoon
uh best by um the movie Strange Brew of
course where they go they go into the
the thing and then they they uh uh
actually uh there won't be a charge for
the beer today because we found a mouse
in our beer and the guy doesn't buy it
he's like get out of here both of you
you're
clowns um but but those have sort of
fancied up over the years now you've got
beer and wine stores in Canada you still
have your provincial BC Liquor beer and
wine store
um but uh well this is good though this
canoli I like it I like it a lot let's
see let's see if we can beat it yeah oh
this one's called cinnamon eggnog oh
[__] cinnamon eggnog it's GNA you know
what it's going to taste like that
sounds pretty good beer it's going to
taste exactly like beer I think it's
going to take like taste like cinnamon
eggnog dude hold on dude yeah I used to
have it in my rider brother that I had a
bunch of Miller lights dude I had a
garbage cam full of Miller lights bro
and then and a sure the boss Andre could
drink whenever he wanted to dude but if
you the iron Chic or Hillbilly Jim you
had to ask nice okay cinnamon what is it
cinnamon eggnog cinnamon
eggnog this is
insane pretty good too it's it's a
little lighter not as flavorful yeah I
like the canoli better right I like the
canoli better
too dude this shit's already like I feel
it going into my bloodstream I'm going
to be drunk I stopped drinking uh
alcohol 11 years ago yeah now here's the
thing about me in alcohol I I was never
much of a beer guy I got to put this
down
um but um I I you know I when I drank it
was tequila and Scotch I really like
tequila and Scotch now I won't say that
I'm cold turkey because of course here I
am having a having a sieron of of uh
dudy dudes evening uh whatever this uh
delicious beer is going to
be but um but uh you all right I'll have
let's going on over
there my point is yeah it doesn't take
much I feel it already in my I do too
and and over the years I'll take like oh
what do you have I I'll have a sip of
that I'll try it I have not had a full
drink in that time and this is every
time we've done this it's been it's been
uh it's been another it's been a [__]
another it's been another to- do here
take another drink okay there you go
thank you so what is this one this
one is chocolate peppermint hey CH
chocolate peppermint and Cheers Cheers I
got to say I'm not a huge fan of
mints [__] that's good too though I got
to say these are all pretty good a
little bit of mint in there uh I think
my preference though is the canoli I got
to say dude well let me try it again see
this is not a good
idea this is more alcohol than I've had
I haven't had this much alcohol since
the last time we taste tested for the
dudy hard hard Seltzer yeah I Dr when we
did a live show I drank almost the whole
dudy hard really yeah I can't I can't
handle alcohol same dude I don't think I
should have done that like like look I'm
I'm I'm not saying like I never had a
problem like I'm fortunate that way I
could get good and pissed we've talked
about this on the show could get good
and [__] hammered with my friends in
my 20s and into my
30s Chad that's [__] gross stop doing
that these are good all right so what
are we going with we landed on the
canoli I just got it's down to the
canoli and the chocolate peppermint the
the middle one I don't remember what it
was called didn't quite hit me the same
hold on Cinnamon eggnog I
think
I'm really I don't want to put the show
at risk and I'm not just saying that
because the show at risk what do you
mean well I want Tear Down the Wall yeah
I'm going to finally I'm going kick
through the [__] screen yeah I'm
going to the screen behind us I'm going
to go over there I'm going to take a run
at it and then we're going to have like
a Looney Tunes uh you know Bugs Bunny
hole in the wall um I don't want to put
I I want to make sure and I'm not saying
this for points okay I'm just I'm giving
you the the real deal here
here I agree with you chocolate covered
canoli all right so that's it we've
we've decided the flavor and we don't
know when this is going to be out but I
assume in time for dude's evening yeah
when you're uh when you're chilling with
your pals and you're having a chill
dudes evening this year uh we hope that
you'll get some chocolate covered canoli
stop it dude stop drinking it but it's
good it is good thank you you moving on
I've created an astonishing partnership
with Harry's you know you get lathered
up you get a nice hot towel you shave
yourself down you feel confident you
don't have any weird flya away hairs you
can even take a little razor and shave
the your ears there a little bit I I
shave the very [__] top of my head
because I have like 17 hairs up there
you know and when I get away from
shaving I feel confident sometimes I
take down the sometimes I get get rid of
all of it you know as you know I'm a
Prof professional actor by trade did you
know that I did know that yeah and uh
you know you you shave you feel
confident uh you you like the way you
look and you're you're ready to uh go on
and take on the world no matter why you
shave Harry's has you covered uh for the
best shave of your life at at a price
that you'll love from their legendary
highquality razors and they are good to
skin products like exfoliating face wash
and Hydrating Lotion Harry's gives you a
premium shave without the premium price
tag get better quality and better price
than other razors when you get Harry's
delivered right to your door and let me
tell you there's no reason not to try
haries they have the highest customer
satisfaction of all uh shaving products
in the Shaving industry get your best
shave ever this summer with Harry's
razors and skincare products get a $13
starter set for just $3 at harri.com
dudy that's harry's.com
dudy for a $3 Starter
Set [__] okay I got to put this down God
I probably still keep drinking a little
bit Yeah here and there I'm tell I'm
going to switch to Coffee I need some
coffee because that was after nearly 5
months the wga strike has come to an end
but its effects on the entertainment
industry are far-reaching and in some
cases completely transformative for some
studios and streamers Netflix saw the
biggest change with their announcement
that Arnold Schwarzenegger will assume
the role of CEO starting next month I
was able to acquire some of his future
plans for the streaming giant will I
want you to have fun with it this is
Arnold Schwarz and Netflix
begin okay well uh Arnold schz Sinker is
not the CEO of Netflix that has not been
announced this is false information yeah
that's not true I mean whatever I guess
that never stops us from doing uh Adam
Sandler going to all the Applebee's and
[__] either so yeah after all this time
doing dudy we should probably oh I'm a
little bit too dude I got a little buzz
on I wouldn't mind seeing [__]
Schwarzenegger taking over Netflix that
could be cool he was the governor of
California [__] State dude that
[__] rolled up and he was like
uh I have little to no political
experience I'm married into a political
family can I be the governor and
everybody's like yeah you're famous
enough we'll vote for you and then after
that everyone else was getting in line
Gary Coleman rest in peace uh there was
that uh the adult film actress Mary Cary
or something like this Mary krey porn
star and uh [__] everyone else got in
line who else Todd Bridges from
Different Strokes did he no Todd Bridges
fought somebody Danny bonuchi fight oh
Danny bonad kick his [__] ass I feel
like that paved the way for what you're
seeing with Logan Paul and all this [__]
who just [__] want to fight this uh
past weekend or whatever yeah uh I think
it was Saturday when the [__] it was but
I'm pretty sure it was Saturday night
versus the idea of like celebrities
becoming Fighters or boxers or whatever
I feel like the Paul Brothers have
really notched it up a level but you
know also Conrad Bane from Different
Strokes the dad he was a fighter yeah he
fought I didn't know that he fought um
Mr the dad from Punky Brewster oh [__]
dude I would have watched that you know
at a at like the studio cafeteria Warner
Brothers or something probably get away
from those [__]
croutons dude it's the warmth that I
miss I think of beer drinking you take a
couple of [__] swig and you get that
first just kind of like ah now you know
after the show sometimes in it does feel
like home doesn't it and that's the
dude's evening feeling uh sometimes in
dudy after dudy we en enjoy a bit a
little bit of tra marijuana yeah um some
uh gabis speaking of um speaking of
[__] uh Petro Canada hitting it up
for a [__] uh hero sandwich you know
what I mean uh my uh I might get into
this after the show in dudes after
but I how am I going to do that my brain
is already we'll see dude what's up with
this Schwarzenegger stuff yeah let's do
this let's do the show yeah
dude yeah dude yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I had too much to
drink I already I also can't believe
I've I drank maybe like a quarter of
this [__] thing a quarter and I'm
already
like I've had let if I'm stop it I've
keep going dude he likes it I do it's
good that's that canoli one a man that's
good that canoli one's good it's really
good and I'm I didn't think I was a
stout guy ah that whole like I skip all
that [__] back when I was drinking beer
it was always logger that's a Canadian
sure give us the logger but the Stout is
that you'd crack an egg in it all that
British [__] you drink it warm I don't
know I don't know all I know is that we
got to do this cuz it's dudy let's get
into it uh it's in my okay my dudy here
yeah Schwarzenegger is the CEO of netfli
the CEO of Netflix all right I've had
seven I'm going to I'm going to estimate
I've had seven good sips of
the that's get [__] dude every once
in a while you can indulge life of
moderation you know what I mean that was
a really good Robert loia okay here we
go it's my best
um okay here it is I'm the governor of
Netflix now Jesus all right right out of
the gate
sure here's some stuff I'm going to do
okay okay the first order of business
I'm going to name Carl Weathers the F
the vice governor of
Netflix yeah okay so they can yeah so
they can go you know they go into the
thing he's like hey what's the matter
FBI got you pushing too many pencils he
go
Dylan you son of a [__] that's I guess
why that would happen right yeah is cars
alive Carl Weathers is alive how old is
he I don't got yeah he's got to be
pushing 80 I met him about 10 years ago
you met him too we were to this ties
into what we were doing on the show on
the patreon at dudy plus patreon.com
dudy we watched waiting to Die the pilot
that you and I wrote and produced for
CBS some years ago and in the same
production office was Michael
Strahan's show that he was doing he
sitcom brothers and uh Carl Weathers was
on it and one week we were walking
through the Halls doing our thing and
someone brought us over and we said
hello what a nice man and then I did a
couple episodes of the show as an actor
I'm a professional actor as a as that's
my profession that's my trade nice dude
yeah good work if you can get it and all
we want to do Netflix is you know what
would be nice when Netflix keeps
inflating its [__] price over and
over again and consumers if you're at
home and you're going why the [__] is
Netflix $15 why is it $20 now it because
is it $20 now I in some cases isn't it
depending on the package you get I have
no idea I don't i' I've had some
chocolate covered canoli the point is
this we're going to get and D let me
just pontificate let me just I'm
shooting from the hip because I've had a
little chocolate covered canoli it's
like an early dude's evening it's dude's
evening in October I feel like it's
dude's evening right now um you know
when you're wondering why is the why is
the price going up and up it's because
these these companies the streamers in
particular are spending billions of
dollars on [__] that may not make them
money but uh the the the uh they won't
share the the data with us the the
analytics on what shows are making money
and then eventually if if that if that
data becomes a little more transparent
those uh you know we're going to go well
wait a minute we're giving we're we're
selling this [__] show everyone's
doing this show it's not making a
[__] dime meanwhile something like
and I don't know that it's streaming on
Netflix but that show Suits was 10 years
ago yeah and now it's getting billions
of views it's become a hit later all
actors are saying is we'd like I think
it's 5758 cents off the price of the
entire package whatever you're giving 20
bucks give us 50 [__] cents divy that
out between all of the actors based on
the the the shows that they're making
that they're appearing in that they're
being their the shows are being built on
their their work their name all of that
value give us 50 [__] cents uh you
know per cycle per month will be divvied
out between all the actors and it's not
happening so maybe Schwarzenegger should
should be the governor of Netflix I
don't know it's possible he could change
things here's the next one all right I'm
I'm going to leave in the middle of my
first meeting and then I'll say I'll be
back but then I never come back and the
people they're waiting all day and I
watch them on the security camera and I
see which ones leave which ones are too
afraid to get fired then I go home and I
never acknowledge it
again yeah yeah yeah yeah and then this
is to teach everyone that I'm not the
guy from the movies anymore oh that's
good strategy just laying down the
[__] log coming in there and being
like [__] you I'm just going to [__]
with everybody oh jeez okay here's
another one these are the dating show
shows we're going to do okay of course
Netflix you know big dating shows yeah
some of the some of the more interesting
uh weird things that are happening in
dating shows would you call 90day fiance
a marriage show it's not dating uh it is
a game it is a dating format game it is
also not on Netflix that one's on HBO
Max but yeah Netflix has all the Chris
colon shows which is Love is Blind
perfect match all that they also have
those ones that are about like dating on
the autism spectrum oh yeah there's one
that's on now about people syndrome
dating Yep they're all great yeah it's
it's interesting stuff well here are the
ones that they're going to do now this
one is called the mingle all the
way yeah it says mingle all the way
dating show yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no
it's not the Christmas no this is dating
show okay but why jingle all the way
it's just a Schwarzenegger it's just
your movie yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
because that's the movie is the jingle
all the way yeah yeah yeah yeah okay I
think get that yeah yeah yeah yeah then
now it's a different cuz it's mingle all
the way okay this next one is called the
the sixth date yeah and that's another
short sger movie the six sixth day then
they changed the name yeah and the last
one is called The Expendables oh
[__] they don't change the name there
okay here's another one uh make it so I
can talk to the people through the TVs
while they watch Netflix hey what are
you watching that would be
cool can you imagine you're [__]
watching stranger things or some [__]
and Arnold schwarzer's voice comes
through your TV hey why are you watching
why you
watching he's just [__] like clicking
in to scare the [__] out of people dude
please let that become a feature on
Netflix please I would love that
actually [__] okay here's another one is
establish a Netflix ha headquarters on
Mars oh Mars yeah yeah that's like the
total recall you know
okay when you take a [__] in the
bathroom you you have to take a picture
of it then you have to print it out and
you post it in the main wall in the
lobby there uh then the biggest [__] of
the week gets a ruths Chris gift
certificate it's a
steakhous yeah what it
says we we had this at Gold's Gym in the
80s I miss it
they were doing that at G gym these body
BS were just putting up pictures of
their shits giving each other steak gift
certificates that makes sense to me that
could possibly be real yep uh God damn
it stinky protein shake [__] yeah dude
[__] it okay here's the next one we they
changed the name back to internet Flix
oh that's nice yeah that's good that's
what it was originally called right
internet fli I guess that's what Arnold
say I don't think that's true no um if
you if you get caught the sheding a p
that's where the predator getss in the
house all right the real Predator yeah I
didn't know it was real yeah oh [__]
mandatory company workout from 5:00 a.m.
to 9:00 a.m. every morning your salary
is dictated by a body mass index I like
that yeah that would be good everybody
doing get the pump yeah you know when
you go you know we go we do the Santa
Monica stairs then you do the kettle
bells you hold the K here he goes
Cannonball
Cannonball that was a good Hulk Hogan um
okay here's another one in in instead of
HR firing people we have running man
Monday the from the movie sure you know
yeah so where you run away from Dynamo
and buz saww and Subzero and then then
if they kill you then you are fired yeah
that's how you know Jesus that's a
[__] hardcore one you have to survive
the The Gauntlet or get killed and fired
dude I'm not I'm not going to lie to you
I think I'm buzzed dude I 100% am 100%
this is bad news
100 dude we like our beer flat ass can
be we like our dogs with mustard and
relish we got a new picture what's his
name where we can't even spell it ding
ding we don't worry about the pen much
we just like to see the boys hit it deep
and nothing like the view from the cheap
seats
around R and around Jeep SE R rer okay
going to tell L fno that we're rebooting
The Hulk and he's going to be the star
of it again but we're really pranking
him the whole time like they did to that
guy on jury duty yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's that's very cruel or yeah that's
interesting show jury duty very
interesting show from the people who did
the joeo show oh was it really I don't
know I have to figure that out because
I'm the governor of the Netflix now Jo
Mo's coming back is it really yeah oh
okay they're doing it again that's a
good idea that of like reality shows
that are like oh we got this thing
happening but there's one person in the
show who doesn't know it's all fake yeah
that shit's about to explode I think
we're going to see a million different
kinds of those shows what if the bach
what if the golden Bachelor is that
right now no I'll tell you what the
bachelor version of it is I already put
some put in some [__] Lego work on
this yeah it's called the host and you
get somebody like Chris Harrison who's
now excommunicated you bring that [__]
back or you get Wells Adams and you say
we have this new reality dating show we
want you to be the host of it everybody
in the show is an actor and we're
[__] with the host dude that's that
is really [__] good I know
dude tell me where I got to be and when
I got to be yeah tell them when you got
to be when you got to be set it up dude
chocolate covered
canoli I'm GNA have another set might as
well
dude might as well go fora nobody hurts
all right gonna make a cartoon movie
about pieces of firewood on
Christmas they're afraid that they're
going get burned up in the fireplace you
see sure yeah but then the family they
go on vacation so the wood that just sit
there but then the family they forgot
the cat and the the it lither box gets
full so the cat makes a piss on the wood
they makes a Biz all over the wood there
and then the family come back and they
smell the biss on the wood no no it's
badwood then they throw it away you see
and this is based on the true story yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah happened in
short s they went away in a cat pistol
on their maybe this happened to him when
he was up in the cabin there in the
Artic and he was there with with his
friend Franco Columbo and then the Mike
H Kier whatever the other guy he came
and they were like oh no it's a polar
bear but it wasn't no it was they were
in the cabin okay uh let's get here's
another one by Hulu
oh I guess that would be the uh yeah buy
it oh okay thank you moving on [__] the
rest of them anyway uh good luck to
Arnold yeah that would I really do want
to see that feature come in where he
could talk to me through my TV yeah that
would be [__] great yeah why are you
watching Suits you can't even watch it
on Netflix or why how did you how did
you even watch a 90day on Netflix it's
on HBO mags hey don't call HBO Max h b
max it's just mags yeah hey why are you
watching Megs that would be cool you're
watching Max and Arnold's like hey don't
walk watch Megs if you have Netflix
installed at all on your TV he can talk
to you through your TV about anything
you're watching or doing he can see
everything that's happening in your
life now I want to take a second to
announce some big news all dudes the
apparel and accessories can now be found
at a brand new location dudy store.com
in celebration of this momentous
occasion I've made some new dudy logo
t-shirts available at dudy store.com
just in time for the holidays and while
you're at dudy store.com you might as
well check out a Hulu hogo cougan shirt
which will be the official undershirt of
every CPA in Illinois during the year
2024 and you can also find yourself a
good job boner mug which fingers crossed
will be the official break room mug at
Netflix once Arnold gets in there the
outgoing CEO of Netflix Tom Hayne knows
the details better than I do but he's
not here to discuss it because he's
promoting his new biopic baloney Mahoney
here's a quick clip from his big
interview with ma
mopy okay Ma mopy dude all right the
pyramidis the Darby franchise uh Uncle
bus potion Pals how many hot dogs did
you have to eat in those movies zero and
what about balone Mahoney
12,900 and
72 that's a lot of hot dogs Tom yeah it
is a lot of hot dogs but that's what the
role required everybody knows how much
baloney Mahoney loved hot dogs this
movie wouldn't have worked if baloney
Mahoney wasn't chain eating hot dogs in
every scene we all knew that going in I
had the option to use computer hot dogs
but blony Mahoney wouldn't have used
computer hot dogs if he was playing
himself so I wasn't going to either uh
you're already getting a lot of Oscar
buzz for this performance one scene in
particular that people are talking about
do you know the scene uh let me guess
the tattoo scene yes the tattoo scene
the tattoo scene my God to I was sobbing
we found the actual tattoo artist who
gave the real bone Mahoney his Infamous
scorpion tattoo and that artist is the
guy in the scene with me and you you
were so deep in this role that you
actually got the tattoo on camera is
that right yeah that's what you're
seeing in that scene I'm actually
getting a baloney Mahoney scorpion
tattoo in the exact same spot baloney
Mahoney got his tattoo right on the
penis that gave theill to thank you so
much for being here
today as always it was my pleasure
everybody needs to see this movie it
really is a once in a-lifetime
experience it's called baloney Mahoney
the true story of the man who invented
baseball okay that movie poster said he
invented baseball so he can eat more hot
dogs
holy [__] dude there's a heavy there's a
bit of a hot dog theme happening with
the show today Tom hay got a [__]
scorpion tattoo on his
penis That's a hardcore actor you ever
do something like that in your
professional acting no I would never
I've never done that I've never gotten a
tattoo for um never gotten that deep in
a rle yeah well you know I've done
things like I've gained and lost weight
for sure movies like um the three stoes
to play curly right I gained four to
play oh dude perfect
um I had uh a good 10
sips same dude whatever I don't know all
right hey if you're enjoying uh today's
episode please subscribe on YouTube uh
and uh hit the notifications so that we
get uh so that you know when we're doing
new stuff and uh please subscribe on
your podcast platform of choice and help
us get over 100,000 we're just a bit
past 60,000
on YouTube right now so we're we're
we're we're we're you know yeah man
we're we're marching up there and we
appreciate you guys watching and this is
the time that I say it but I always feel
it um also please follow us on our
socials at uh dudy pod show on Instagram
so much insane stuff all of our pods P
of dudy out there that uh send us memes
and videos people making all sorts of
[__] [__] uh more recently if I if I
may Frank Von Vox I know that dude's
just turning it out shit's incredible
BTK
dopod uh Johnny Johnny uh Johnny B from
OKC these are people that are constantly
making stuff they're in our community
and we really we appreciate you guys
doing that we're also on Tik Tok and
Facebook at those uh at those handles
and uh uh want to thank everybody who's
subscribing to us on patreon we call it
dudy plus and uh if you would like like
to support the show you can do so
patreon.com dudy 7 bucks a month gets
you all of our content brand new episode
of dudy after dudy after every show a
bunch of watch alongs and [__] like that
all all that flavor please uh share the
show with everyone you know on social
media or follow Chad's light suggestion
to force everyone you know to enjoy the
Pod show yeah have fun with it [__]
2: a.m. y uh your partner's asleep in
the bed next to you just as loud as you
can crank up yourself phone or your iPad
right in the face because we want to
continue to do this [__] show I love
doing this show and and um I've been
feeling it a lot you know and sometimes
I I can't quite figure out how to
intimate it out
there especially right in the middle of
the show when I should just
be I shouldn't be doing this I had 10
you doing I don't even know what the
[__] happening yeah I don't know
either all right you know what I mean
yeah dude hey you know now would be a
good time for you to uh do all that
stuff I'll give you a little moment a
little pause so that you can subscribe
you can hit the notifications and and
then we'll we'll join you right back
here here right now we we'll give you a
moment to do that and welcome back and
if you uh yourself have a podcast that
you're doing and you would like to have
guests on that podcast and you want one
of those guests to be me you just send
an email to book Chad culture gmail.com
I answer them in the order received and
I go and I do three of these podcasts
every Saturday from 10: to 10:20 from
10:20 to 10:40 from 10:40 to 11:00 a.m.
PST every Saturday had some great ones
this past week I went on one that was
called uh fure and it was a five minute
podcast all about super fandom of
Frasier that's amazing yeah it was
really fun what did you have to say
about that are you only five minutes so
you know I was like I'm a big Frasier
fan and that was basically it we talked
about money plane money plane oh my gosh
we saw this movie money plane recently
with Adam Copeland Edge who we talked
about on the show wrestlers are actors
as you know and did you know that I'm a
professional actor by TR hey never mind
uh it's incredible that you do what you
do Chad every weekend he's on these pod
shows and uh and uh that's that's really
something else speaking to that when you
when you're interacting with the show
please leave a comment wherever it is
whether it's patreon Instagram Facebook
Tik Tok or YouTube I'm going to read
some YouTube
comments and I need some water and some
coffee because I've had yeah dude more
beer than I've had in 20
years in the past 45 minutes or so nice
D oh oh now I'm starting to Chad that's
gross don't burp on this sorry okay this
one is from fake Bobby Hill 296 on
YouTube who
writes I hope dudy gives will a belt
before he just gives up on it dudy trick
to manipulate will will only work for so
long without telling him without letting
him get a taste of the carrot on the
stick now yeah uh I this is your listen
fake Bobby Hill you're just you're just
copying what Chad says what my pal Chow
says about me being manipulated I
disagree I'm not it's not about me
getting a bite of the carrot I
appreciate your your uh your opinion
Chad anything to say about that I 100%
agree with fake Bobby Hill
okay and I believe for that reason
you'll get the belt at some
point I'm not I don't need you to tell
me that I'm you think I'm going to get
the belt that's not what it's
about okay what what do you mean it's
about about the show I don't give a [__]
about and you know what it's like I'm
shooting from the hip on stuff with
um but I'm Sho I've been shooting from
the hip today on the show and it's not
just the 10 sips of beers talking sh d
uh I'm shooting from the hip saying hey
here's here's a situation like the SAG
strike where among other things that
we're dealing with uh in in these issues
with the with the strike and trying to
restructure a contract now I got into I
got into the the sort of well what
happens with residuals these are things
that for that haven't been revised some
of these points in 40 years since the
strike in like the 1980 881 or whatever
the [__] it happened and now more
recently like uh whenever this happened
like 15 years ago they were like well
these are new technologies we don't
understand that's all online well it's
publicity it's not really you know
content uh we we have a growing number
of issues not the least of which is AI
and I don't want my likeness look at him
look at him look how look at look at the
guy look at his face look at how he Hees
he thinks it's a non-issue he thinks
we're all just going to be happy to have
ai you just don't have a choice dude
like it's happening oh oh I'm sorry I
can't make content I can't be now don't
say what I think you're going to say say
but I can't be part of a show like dudy
yeah I can't uh uh be on show that's run
by an AI and represent myself and be who
I want to be and not worry about that
carrot fake Bobby Hill no I'm going to
do exactly what the [__] I want free
will on the show all right I think
that's what dudy
wants dude and then to say that it's
manipul all right okay let's say here's
another one uh this one's
[__] all right uh this one's from a
awesom btics who says I started watching
at episode 72 and went went back and
watched from the beginning and it's
amazing how much dudy has evolved in his
comedy and personality I love his sense
of humor uh interesting I will also say
that if you are just uh joining us you
know in the show more recently welcome
to it and I think it's a good thing to
start with season two what do you think
yeah I agree I agree with with
everything that was said here I think
dudy uh personality has definitely like
absolutely evolved in season 2 and is
much funnier he is doing weirder [__]
funnier [__] hell yeah I I agree D look
D now I'm going to say I said what I
meant about Ai and you continue to say
what I mean because that's what I do
sure uh because that's well that's free
will dude um uh dudy is the most
sensient
AI out there in my opinion and uh uh it
has made a bunch of changes for season 2
and I welcome it and I'm shaking d D's
hand and uh I've had 10 sips of of beer
but my point stands you can start at
season two and then go back and go
through season one and it's a good time
it's okay to start with season two this
one is from Lee Miller 333 I watched
louder milk on Amazon and was shocked
when Will Sasso came on I almost forgot
that he's a professional actor by trade
good show did you know that I'm a
professional actor by I have been told
that yeah hey speaking of streamers I'm
going to put I'm going to put I you know
what hopefully I'm going to put 57 cents
in the streamer Pockets right now and
I'm going to say go check out louder
milk on Amazon nice dude and then you
can go [__] buy a you know whatever
the [__] you want a a pickle ball racket
over there if you want nice dude louder
milk's some of the most fun I've had on
a television program we did three
seasons of it last one this is from
James Cary 982 I got to admit I think
Chad is spoton with the NFL Swift thing
the Taylor Swift NFL thing yeah yeah you
nailed it they won they won this past
weekend and she was in attendance it's
gonna keep going she's got the biggest
concert in the world now the biggest
movie in the world the NFL wants all of
that press some people don't like it
some people are like it's taken away
from what the Integrity of the sport
blah blah blah all sports are [__]
entertainment they're TV shows and if
you get big famous people to be in your
TV show it's always going to help I
can't I can't I cannot disagree I can't
I can't disagree with that although I
just think they're just two two just two
sweet kids looking for love sure dude
sure sure hey guys remember last week
when I asked you both to bring in your
astonishing pieces of Alf paraphernalia
well it's time to show me what you got
this is object's du Alf
begin okay you want to go first or
second well totally up to you what would
you like uh
uh I'll go first Chad will go first last
week dud uh dudy showed us a bunch of
pictures during a standard psychological
evaluation and they were all of Al
hosting the Tonight Show and I don't
know what the [__] that was about I saw
some interesting comments online oh what
do you got there as you know I collect
cards yeah you big card mag Gathering
cards I started getting WWE and when I
was younger I collected all kinds of
weird cards like Batman the movie cards
and I got these this is a box of Alf
trading cards from [__] I don't know
when this is 1985 or something that's
dope yeah dude we're gonna open some
holy [__] wait a minute when did you get
those I've had these forever dude you've
had Alf trading cards yeah you really
are a card guy I love cards Dude I love
cards Dude now dude this has gum in
it I'm just letting you know in case you
might want some I'm going to eat the gum
here have a couple of packs of Al cards
I can open these yeah dude dude you've
had these for a while and I'm going to
open them yeah dude we're both going to
open some they don't oh they smell they
smell just a little bit like uh like gum
like some Bazooka Joe dude this is
incredible okay let's open some cards so
these are from Wow
1987 alien Productions all rice Reserve
this gum is stuck to the card but this
gum doesn't this gum doesn't have black
spots on it dude you might be all right
this gum stuck to the card too yeah yeah
all right let's see what we got here we
got a boo baseball uh card for The speld
Spar calamari Ben Chuchu tramer I
remember this there was a a thing called
bullia baseball in like the world of Alf
and um I guess they had bullia baseball
cards in here here's a sticker of Al how
about a hug for the old alfer yeah I
want to see here there's some
interesting ones there's here's one it
says it says hey I'm supposed to be the
one with the silly hair
Willie how's it going Alf I told you not
to use the vacuum cleaner look at this
one why did you use what is that one I
don't know if you can read it it's the
daughter of the family and Al and a cat
and Alpha saying I can see it's a cat
but where's the soy
sauce that's pretty good oh some of this
gum fell off ah with the mom it says
smile when you call me
repulsive yeah oh it's not gum anymore
[__] ow tops was just cranking it out
back then they were like you got a
property you want some [__] cards
we'll make them we don't give a [__] you
going to eat the gum no dude you want it
yep so it's not good for you this G no
it doesn't taste like gum
either yeah I I uh I can't believe
you're eating it honestly I'm not sure
another bullia baseball card the Rosen
Bloom Phantom St Stanley Mouse breath
yikes a middle
scooper it's almost like dudy ball boo
baseball hey dude's ball remember that
yeah dude who ordered the grilled
broccoli and tuna flavored soda
okay hey how come my bow tie doesn't
spin it's a good one these are basically
just scenes from the show with like
comic book speech bubbles next to their
head to do the dialogue from the show
that's what these [__] cards are yeah
this one is a picture of him next to a
jackal lanter it says you remind me of
someone I knew back on
Melmac that's pretty good dude that's
pretty funny well these are amazing Chad
I can't believe that you [__] have
these these are my paraphernalia my
paria that's incredible so what do you
got well here may I yeah thank you
there's no spittle gum in there I spat
it back into my dudy mug oh nice dude
well I um don't have uh paraphernalia
from a long time ago so I had I had to
get it and it's not just because because
dudy told me to it's it's uh it's
actually like a lot of things on today's
episode of dudy it's coming from a real
place okay um and I want to keep it real
because I am keeping it real keep it
real because you're keeping it real yeah
and and and uh you know we're in the
fall months now y um and uh we just had
a [__] Heatwave in California so
maybe it's not yeah the same thing but
I'll be up in Canada soon and this is
going to come in handy so it's something
that I actually really I really like I
went I found this I actually got it on
amazon.com where you can watch
Loudermilk and where Arnold swarzenegger
will yell at you hey why are you
watching louy milk don't watch that yeah
come to
Netflix this is a uh you would call it a
knit cap in America and I oh wow call it
a toque it's my Al to yeah looks like Al
Yep looks like elf that's what I got I
got an Al toque and and before you
before you guess that I'm not going to
wear this on the street and in my life I
want you to know I will wear this please
I want you to keep record of who comes
up to you and knows what the [__] that
is I think a lot of people will I think
that for the same reason that you and I
are as dudy has said yeah such massive
Al fans right we're probably gonna I'm
probably gonna get hey oh [__] hey oh
[__] [__] hey you go if it's [__]
cold up in Canada you can wear your
[__] toque your Al toque and when you
go to the pan before you go to The
ladner's Landing at the drive-thru and
get a few [__] molsen or molon ice
cuz it's got a higher alcohol content eh
oh I didn't know that oh yeah yeah and
then uh go to Petro Canada to get your
[__] uh Old Dutch chips e don't
forget a dude's evening uh Stout oh this
isn't the [__] chocolate covered
canoli it's the chocolate peppermint uh
uh uh you can also get uh good chocolate
at the Petro Can CU it got those
Canadian chocolate bars I know before
you became n bars yeah oh [__] Nimo bars
Nimo yeah before you uh became a vegan
you were really into the Wonder Bar
loved it that was still to this day
probably my favorite candy bar yeah I
remember I'd go over to Chad's place
never mind thank you moving on Good
Times
today is National Mulligan day a day
devoted to the power of the reset and
redo in celebration of this astonishing
holiday I thought it might be fun for
each of you to talk about something
you'd like to get a doover on this is
today is the day National Mulligan Day
begin okay very interesting okay we've
done this before today is the day
national days are usually [__] weird
National Mulligan day very interesting
this is something that I've thought
about often I don't know if this
is this is something that I've thought
about often I'll say that much I love
making little songs and [__] on my
computer yeah you do had that technology
existed when I was in junior high 100% I
would be doing music as a career really
yeah and not that I want like a doover
necessarily because I like writing I
like making art and all this [__] too
but gross Chad I mean literally I was
speaking there's no way that I could
have done both of those things hey I'm
sorry everybody you know we're kind of
shooting from the but yeah dude I I
would say in terms of a mulligan I I
always knew that I want to do something
creative when I was a kid and writing
just seemed like the easiest thing cuz
like you didn't have to have much
equipment for it but now that you can
get like uh Logic Pro or even Garage
Band just like standard on a Mac I think
if that had been around when I was a kid
I definitely would be doing that as a
career I I I think that's awesome for
you but Chad it's like it's like it's
like the whole idea of a mulligan is the
do over mhm I love your music youve you
do you remember well of course you
remember I should be talking to you guys
do you remember on 10-minute podast when
we did micro decisions yeah dude I
remember that oh God that music was
Chad's music that was some of Chad's
music some early works yeah dude he he
makes some really interesting music yeah
uh listen there are people nowadays on
Soundcloud you know of course I mean we
a couple of old head here trippy red um
you know [__] uh oh who's there's uh
young lean Taylor Swift yep Taylor Swift
is a big SoundCloud she started on
YouTube did she yeah I don't remember
that much I just I just did Bieber I've
had yeah well Bieber started on Ellen or
I think she was on the I think he was on
the ma show
oh hey remember uh in uh on the when
look at him
how the [__] have you had just as much
of the dude's evening do you know what
that's what an episode Champion does
dude all right well I'm going to keep it
real because I'm keeping it real and uh
I want to tell you you should pursue
that you know people like post Malone
and stuff got no time what I ain't got
no time to do music hell no I think the
thing about a mulligan is it's it's
nothing if you don't actually put it
into uh into action and I've been this
is interesting because dudy does know
all in the weirdest way dudy does you
know it's in touch with us in in ways
that we don't understand it's listening
on our phones like the [__] NSA is
probably and [__] I mean I know that for
a fact because of the stuff that it
makes us too I have been I've been
thinking a lot about this and this is
this is uh this is just this is just the
way it is I this is truly how I feel I
in that the strike has been happening
now for 3 months for the actors it went
went on for five months Y for the uh for
the Raiders not having my primary career
which is acting not having
that um you know just in my life I miss
it and I I we all want to feel a sense
of purpose you know you know in our in
in our lives and I realize that um I've
got this wonderful gift I get to do this
show and I get to hang out with y'all
and crack wise with my good pal chow and
uh just be uh be a silly goose and I
enjoy it so [__] much it really is
the highlight of my week
and sometimes when I think about the way
the show started and where we are now
and some of the you know some of the
back and forth and the [__] that
I've had with dudy in that time if I
were to have a mulligan this is pretty
you know a po I would have a different
attitude towards dudy interesting yeah
you could just do that now I could do
that now and I I I want to do that now
and I I'm trying to I'm trying to do
that now and I I I feel like I
don't if I can give myself a critique
which I can give myself many critiques I
underestimate things I underestimate
things sometimes I underestimate
something that I'm involved with okay
and uh I think that that uh that forms
my reality cuz if you underestimate you
know whatever whatever you think about
yourself you're right
right maybe I don't know I have dreams
all the time where I'm playing for the
Lakers and LeBron James has given me his
jersey so that I can go into the game
and win it for the Lakers I don't think
that's right that's a nice
overestimation yeah that's what I'm
talking about that's literally a
recurring dream I have that's [__]
cool yeah it's pretty I think that's I
think that's great you want to take that
shot yeah that's you know every great
Lakers has always wanted the ball when
the when the chips are down that's right
and uh I sometimes feel like if I can
give myself a big critique it's like the
Groucho marks quote I'd rather not be
member to a club that would have me sure
and I don't want to peel the onion and
get to uh maybe it's something we can
talk about in dudy after dudy but I want
to uh bring Who I Really Am to this
program I've been uh away from U making
TV shows movies which I am so fortunate
to be able to do as a career mentioning
something like louder milk that I got to
do with you know with the incredible
Pete Fairley and and Bobby Fairley and
and uh Ron Livingston and just just an
incredible [__] show and so much fun
and I really love to act I also love to
create and make things and do [__] and
do weird [__] and you talk about making
music I've made all sorts of things that
don't see the light of day and [__] and
perhaps I should invest myself more into
it and believe that it's going to reach
a lot of people and and that's something
that I want to bring to dudy that's my
Mulligan that I want to and you're
you're right Chad it's not it's not too
late I I feel like since season 2 has
begun I have had a bit of a new attitude
towards dudy whether it's uh positive or
negative it's really uh who I am and if
I'm not just being who the [__] I am
what the [__] am I even bothering doing
this pod show
for you mad at me what's going on here
you got real real mad there at the turn
turn to the darkness no I'm not I'm not
I'm not mad I'm saying I I want this
show to be great me too yeah and I'm
gonna I'm gonna that's what I'm taking
with me today I'm GNA I believe I
believe in this [__] show and I don't
want I I don't want to underestimate it
want to
overestimate great thank you moving on I
I'll I'll sub in I'll sub into to that
game nice I literally this concludes the
robust 78th episode of dudy Will and
Chad you scored a 73 bringing your
cumulative total to
7,344 you only have
2,656 more points to acrew before you
reach your first goal of 10,000 next
week you're both off from the normal pod
show because I want you to help me with
the launch of the brand new dudes
Eclipse channel so I'll need you the
studio at our usual time to show you a
few Cs and get your reactions I'm
especially curious to see what you think
of some stuff from the very beginning of
dudy and then the week after that you
got to get all dressed up because it's
Halloween I want to see both of my boys
wearing your most astonishing Halloween
get up holy [__] we've got a fun few
weeks ahead thanks to everyone for
joining us this week until next week
call me dudy amazing oh man this is this
has been a good one this has been a very
interesting show uh we're going to go
back to tomorrow and plan for yesterday
or whatever right uh next week no show
we're off but we also are not I guess
because we will be here uh introducing
you to some clips and dudy has a Clips
Channel yeah so I'm sure all the
information will be uh made available
through all of those channels holy
[Music]
[__]
[Applause]
hey
hey Cannonball coming Cannonball
Cannonball
time ah man it's dudy after dudy it's
the dad time and this is when we just
kind of kick back and really just crack
wise and silly goose it up you know it's
two dudes [__] around after all
right Chad sure dude we got no other
choice
and um um I've had uh now 12 sips of um
is that have you consumed a whole can
yet no oh yeah probably cumulatively I
would say I would say so so you know
welcome to dudy after dudy we hope
you're uh checking it out you know
because we're on dudy after dudy
patreon.com d dud after
dud dud
welcome to dudy after dudy the flagship
weekly show of dudy plus if you'd like
to join us visit patreon.com dudy I just
want to say that whatever happens today
with the belt I'm positive this is
working and that's a win in my books
I'll be back in a few to let you know
who won this week this is dudy after
dudy begin okay well yeah dudy works in
mysterious ways hey at the end of the
the end of this episode of dudy after
dudy just like every other uh dudy after
dudy um dud is gonna tell us who the
dude's the episode Champion is look at
him look at him look at this guy he's
very very confident about holding on to
that title all I can do is what I do do
do till it's done done done Chad that's
what I was talking about earlier sure
having a good attitude towards the sing
not just having a good attitude it's
about having a real attitude it's about
yeah it's about for me for me it's about
Free Will more and more sure I I know
that you say that Free Will is an
illusion and that it doesn't exist yeah
okay well that's a good that's a good
theory and you know what I like your
theory also I I find it very interesting
thank you but
um uh speaking of free will I I just
want to here's what I would like to do
right now I wonder if you would like to
to hey Chad you know the the new trailer
for Timothy
shalam willly Wonka just dropped yes
dude I have not yet seen this but I knew
that it came out you want to watch it
[__] yeah dude you
like tell
a if you like d what you
do please tell a friend
thenie if you like d here what you
do please tell a friend then